Nicole is with us Nicole is in Michigan
hi Nicole how are you I'm fine David how
are you better than I deserve what's up
well a year and a half ago a young man
ran a stop sign a little no vehicle with
me and my children in it we have been on
a route uh great for this last year and
a half because of this we have insurance
money coming our way and my husband and
I want to do the best we can possibly do
and make some good choices with this
money and we don't know where to begin
so I'm calling you for help okay how
much insurance settlement will you get
from the wreck a hundred and twenty
thousand is coming your phone's breaking
up can you speak directly into it please
yes a hundred and twenty thousand is
coming from the first settlement okay is
that all there is a second settlement
that will be happening towards the end
of October but we don't know what that
amount will be the gentleman was working
for a large corporation so the insurance
policy is very large I have a head
engine and I can no longer return to a
professional level which I was I was in
administration and so with of that being
I've lost the capability of working so
my lawyer is thinking it's going to be
upwards in the million dollar range Wow
okay and what did you use donor I was at
forty thousand a year my husband I guess
it doesn't matter if I was at the forty
thousand dollar that is anyone else
injured or do you need ongoing care does
anyone need ongoing care from this money
I need ongoing care yes for my head
injury I'm still in all kinds of therapy
I passed three surgeries this year both
of my children were injured and they are
now recovering to the best possibility
there were only three and six
so they still have ongoing issues but as
far as their long-term prognosis it's
really good thank God yeah amen
well the reason I asked is is that we
need to set aside money for that care
your care or their care first sure
before we do anything then secondly
we've got to think about the household
has lost $40,000 worth of income and how
are we going to offset that there's two
ways you can offset that one is to use
the money to reduce debt so your
expenses are going down like you could
pay off your mortgage as an example and
that'd be a big help out of them out of
a million dollars how much is your
mortgage we our total debt including our
mortgage our truck all of our loans is
only a hundred thousand dollars then
that makanda becomes a no-brainer I'd
write a check and pay off the hundred
thousand dollars what does your husband
make a year 1773 and you know then we've
got his income and no debt and then you
use the rest of the money I'm talking
about after we've set us out enough for
your care mm-hmm any ongoing surgeries
or care we set that aside first
secondly I'd pay off all the debt third
I would invest it and and let the
investments create income that offsets
the fact that you lost your income that
is a big question mark I'm a dummy when
it comes to investing we've never been
in a position to be able to do any
investing to even think about investing
so I have no idea where to even start
with that here's a couple of rules and
if you follow these two rules you'll be
okay
well three rules okay number number one
rule go slow you don't have to be a
genius overnight okay number two rule do
not put money in anything until and
unless you understand it not because I
said to not because some guy does good
suit said to it's your money you're the
one that's going to be affected it's
your responsibility it's your life do
not put money in something unless you
can call me up and tell me how that
investment works
meaning you understand it okay because
you want more if you understand it and
you're making the decision you won't
worry and you won't make mistakes
not many okay okay third is you need
someone in your corner to help advise
you on this now
the mistake that most people make when
they pick an advisor is they pick
someone to do the work for them I don't
want them to do that I want them to
teach you and you make the decision you
are the one that's responsible I'm not
responsible for your million dollars
that advisor shouldn't be responsible
for the million dollars you are
responsible and so take your time don't
put money in something you don't
understand and meet with someone who can
increase your understanding an adviser
that has the heart of a teacher not the
heart of a Salesman sure okay let me
tell you when I'm meeting with a young
NFL star a young football star and I'm
trying to explain to him that NFL stands
for not for long you know he's not gonna
be there very long and he shouldn't
might take advantage of the time while
he's there and he let me tell you if he
says this phrase to me I know he's gonna
leave the league broke and the phrase
they say to me sometimes is I got me a
man translation I'm turning all of the
responsibility and the understanding of
my investments over to someone and I
have no freaking clue that is the
definition of a young man getting ready
to lose all his money you follow me I
got you yeah and you're gonna be just
exactly the opposite that you're gonna
be going slow you're meeting with
someone that has the heart of a teacher
and you're not gonna invest in it until
you understand it once you're doing all
of that
I would lead you towards understanding
mutual funds and how they work and what
they are and I would invest in four
types of growth stock mutual funds I
know I would do that because it is what
I have done and its growth growth and
income aggressive growth and
international and I pick mutual funds
that
of a very long track record I do not
invest in a mutual fund that's been open
two years or three years I invest in
them that have been open 10 or 20 or 30
or 40 I have one mutual funds been open
75 years and I can tell the average of
what it's done for 75 years that gives
me a lot of comfort if that thing is
performed at X rate for 75 years I'm
pretty comfortable with that and then I
don't have to freak out when I turn on
the news and Trump burped on Twitter and
the stock market went sideways I'm not
freaked out about that I'm gonna ride
this thing out he's been this thing's
been around 75 years it has endured
Republicans and Democrats for 75 years
it's made money so I can just be calm I
can ride with that thing but I
understand it and the more understanding
I have the more peace I will have around
it financial peace it's about being
content where you are and it's about
understanding your investments or don't
put money in them and let me just tell
you to go on another sidebar on this you
know you're asking all the right
questions Nick also click smart Wester
at Dave Ramsey comm you can find the
smart Vista pros we recommend they don't
work for me
but these are qualified investing
professionals that are near you that we
have vetted and they have the heart of a
teacher and they'll go slow with you and
you take your time and you understand it
and get someone with the heart of a
teacher and you're gonna be just fine
I'm sorry you've been through this
horrible wreck kiddo